the first 50 Asylum Seekers to be housed
at the former Air Base at Wethersfield
in Essex crossed the channel by small
boat over the weekend they were brought
here straight from processing centers in
Kent
earlier cameras were unusually allowed
to film the facilities inside this is
where Asylum Seekers will sleep two or
three to a room where they will be
provided with three meals a day and
snacks the gym and sports facilities
they can use to occupy their time the
government's message using Surplus
military sites like this is cheaper for
taxpayers than costly hotels
the home office says Asylum Seekers will
have everything they need on site and
won't burden the resources of local
communities but in what appears to be an
acknowledgment of the upset and concerns
felt by some locals when Asylum Seekers
First arrive they'll also be given
instructions on how to be good neighbors
everybody who arrives here is goes
through an orientation process to
understand what acceptable behavior is
we know that they've been through quite
a lengthy journey and they're in a new
environment and it's important they
understand how to fit in and be part of
the community and minimize any impact
in the quintessentially English Villages
near to the base they fought hard to
prevent this day from happening a legal
challenge to the plan is continuing
through the courts many people here so
the intended number of 1700 Asylum
Seekers at the base by the Autumn will
overwhelm their communities a mixture of
disappointment
fear amongst some because the messages
coming from the government and our own
Home Secretary are so flawed so mixed
their reassurance is given by the home
office simply not good enough or
reassuring enough for these communities
those who work with Asylum Seekers also
oppose the move we should be treating
them with humanity and dignity welcoming
them into our communities like we did
with refugees from Ukraine rather than
warehousing them in former military
barracks in the middle of nowhere where
it's wholly inappropriate to place them
this is the first of a number of large
sites the government wants to repurpose
to house Asylum Seekers it will need
others if the promise to reduce small
boat Channel Crossings remains
unfulfilled Lisa Holland Sky News Essex
foreign